so yeah I'm mark young this is a servant
we're from from Aiden's we're a startup
based here in Amsterdam actually in the
geysers trucks are very close by and
we've been working on applying deep
learning to medical imaging for about a
year and a half now
and what we think we've achieved some
nice results that we are eager to show
to share with you and explain a little
bit about how we're doing that and
perhaps you can provide us with some
feedback as well on maybe how we can
still improve it so what are we talking
about here
well what we're working on is detecting
early stage lung cancer and lung cancer
is starts in lung nodules and lung
nodules are very small deviations in
your lung tissue you can see the picture
which is an actual slice meaning a
horizontal slice through somebody's body
you can see two lungs and with a lot of
I know bronchial arteries hearts spine
SATs and lung tissue and at the red
arrow there is a lung nodule so as you
can imagine this is actually quite
difficult to detect and but it's
important to detect them because once
you are able to find them you can treat
them and then if you can treat people in
this early stage they can recover and
they'll live which is good for them and
by the time it's very easy to detect
along artists and when they've grown
into a cancerous mass it's often too
late so you can still treat people but
they'll likely die so there's been
Studies on how how to to use this
knowledge to improve the detection rate
of lung cancer and the best way to do
that is to screen everybody who is a
high risk of lung cancer which is
unsurprisingly people who have smoked a
lot so everybody who smoked a lot of
cigarettes and is older than about 55
years old should be screened using a CT
scan and the first thing of course you
have to do on that scan is detected
there is something wrong and then you
can decide what to do with it so far
people do this right radiologists they
take your scans they look
and they try to find these visual
deviations the maximum sensitivity you
have as a person as an as a trained
radiologist who does this for a living
is about 80% meaning you miss about 20%
one in five so yeah if you're the one in
five that they miss that makes you
unhappy so the question is can we do
something about that with software
there's a technical challenge here as
well besides a clinical one is that
finding these things is actually pretty
darn difficult because the the data set
that you're looking at one scan is a 3d
volume of let's say 50 million to 100
million fossils so a 200 million
features that you have to analyze to
figure out if there's something there
there's an example of a lung nodule
actually it's quite a big one on the on
the page as well so the data set that
we're using to train on is about 5 5
terabytes and since these things are so
large you can't just fit them and throw
in a complete 3d volume at one end and
this output a label at the other end and
expect your network to train just
doesn't work like that even if it would
work it would take awfully long time
because there's so much data so the
question is then how do you do this well
of course the first thing you try is
when you have a lot of data then you buy
bigger servers right so this is the last
one we bought actually these because
GeForce GTX 10-days came in yesterday so
we still have to put them into a server
so we're hoping that by using one server
with eight of these things will improve
our training times a little bit more you
also run into some practical problems
with these things because it turns out
when you put one of these in Iraq at a
hosting party it will melt their their
power cables so you have to upgrade all
kinds of stuff to be able actually you
can put one of these servers in Iraq
that's meant for a 44 year ex so you
learn as you go along okay that was my
introduction I'll hand over to Kevin to
do more detailed technical stuff all
right thank you so the way we tackle
this challenge is we created a pipeline
with a series of stages there is a
pre-processing stage a localization
stage a post-processing stage and a
boosting stage and I will explain each
of these but the most important thing to
remember here is that the output of one
stage is used as the input of the next
so let's start with the pre-processing
stage the pre-processing stage takes in
a series of scan and it sometimes there
are multiple series and then we can pick
which one is the best
so some scans may have a high resolution
or better quality and then we will pick
that one instead of other scans and this
is the way CT scans are processed
sometimes there are multiple versions of
them and the next step is reading in
that scan and that scan has been
followed the DICOM standard which is a
format a standard for medical images and
so we have to yeah we read that scan in
and we perform very various consistency
checks in order to see whether we can
handle that scan and whether it has been
made correctly that has better there
hasn't been an error in in saving scan
so then when we have read scan and it
passes all the checks we then scale it
to a common resolution so that every
scan has the same resolution because
this can vary in resolution as well and
so we use the resolution seen on screen
so that the network that we put scan in
doesn't have to work on different
resolutions right so then we have the
pre-processing stage the next step is to
use that scan that we came out of the
pre-processing that which is basically a
numpy array now in Python and put it in
our localization Network the
localization network is a network that
detects nodules
and basically what we want to achieve
with this network is we want a very high
sensitivity and what that means is that
we want to find as many of the nodules
that are present in the volume and we
don't care at this stage about any false
positives we want to minimize them of
course but we want to achieve very very
high so it's basically like 97% of the
nodules sensitivity and what we train on
is a label that is as big as the scan
and we annotate on this on this label we
annotate the nodules as as bounding
boxes where they can be found so the
label is basically a one where there is
a nodule and zero where there isn't and
so the output of the network is a
probability map of whether for each
voxel whether that foxhole falls in side
of a nodule so let me explain this
localization Network a little bit more
so what we want to achieve is that we
want we don't want to specify size of
the volume that we put into the network
and we can achieve that in tensor flow
which is the framework that we are using
to to create our deep learning networks
is by
defining a dynamic shape and you can
accomplish by this by using known as the
shape size for for each of the spatial
dimension XY and Z and that's that's
making the network not care about the
size of the volume that we put in which
is very important because this can vary
in size also because we want to apply to
huge volumes we cannot use certain
Network features like strided
conclusions or max pooling because that
would reduce the input and we want the
output to be as large as the input
because we want the probability map of
where the nodes are to be the same size
as the input volume a last trick that we
use is because if you use a normal
convolutional net we wouldn't we would
have to use a lot of layers if we aren't
aloose allowed to use strident
convolution or max pooling so what we
use is dilated convolutions and those
are basically convolutions which have
zeros in the filter inserted and you can
see here on the image that this would be
a normal 3x3 convolution and with
dilated conclusions basically the white
pixels here are zeros and so you create
a much larger convolution but you don't
have that many more parameters or even
the same amount of parameters in this
case and so the whole network can be
seen as one giant convolution therefore
can be applied to any size for you like
we wanted to furthermore we use the rest
net architecture and this is an
architecture that has been successfully
used in many problems the main reason I
will just explain first what the
resonant architecture does
I'll assume that convolutional nets are
known at this point so basically what
the rest net architecture does is when
when you have a convolution applied you
add it to the input that it is applied
on so here you can see these weight
layers are convolutional layers and then
there's an activation function in the
middle they're rectified linear
activation function and you take the
input you put it through those
convolutions but you at the end you add
the convolutions to the input and this
way the gradient flows better to each
layer in your network and therefore you
have don't have problems with exploding
or vanishing gradients which is a common
problem in a very deep large networks
that have that we use and by using this
resonant architecture we alleviate this
problem also you can see a code snippet
here in tensor flow and this shows you
how easy is it is to set up this kind of
residual Network architecture in the
intensive flow basically the image that
you see on the left has been translated
here to code and you can see the two
convolutions here with the rectified
linear activation function in the middle
and here the copy is made to the input
as a edits to the input there and most
of our network contains 2d conclusions
but the whole network is actually a 3d
network and because we don't use as much
context in the in the z-axis we don't do
a lot of 3d convolutions but most of the
network is kept 2-dimensional and the
way we do this is when we have a 3d
volume we reshape it to be a to the
volume for the time being and then we
apply the 2d conclusions that we want
and then afterwards we reshape it back
to 3d again and the way we can do that
intensive flowers using the reshape
function and we basically when you have
a normal input to a 3d neural network it
would be the dimensions would be batch Z
Y and ax and the channel dimensions and
we reshape it to join the batch in the z
axis and so we basically make it a 2d
volume by seeing all these other slices
in the Z dimension as separate inputs to
the 2d convolutions one other trick that
we use is his weight normalization and
this has actually been developed by Tim
Solomon's which is a scientific adviser
of our company and works for open AI and
he he made by Thomas ation to be a more
practical is to implement methods to to
tackle the exploding or vanishing
gradient problem that I talked to you
about before basically in most Nets when
they're they get very deep the gradients
get either 0 or they explode and by
using a technique called batch
normalization you can you can alleviate
a problem but it's very expensive to to
run on large networks by using weight
organization you can also fix this
problem and it's much easier to
implement what we do is when we have
weight of a conclusion we redefine them
in terms of a magnitude and a direction
and here you can see formula of that and
this is the new weight and we we
normalized the old ways the normal ways
by dividing dividing them by the
magnitudes and their therefore we have a
normalized vector here and then we add
an extra scale factor in front of it and
so we basically you basically better
define the parameter space in a
different way which helps which helps
the gradients flow to different layers
better also this is much easier to
implement and it distributes over a lot
of GPUs very easily so other tricks that
we use our data augmentation we train on
linearly scaled and translated inputs of
the volume which which gives us a lot
more data because we don't have a lot of
positive data there are not a lot of
modules learning modules in in a volume
and therefore data augmentation is key
to perform to getting good results also
we don't use very large networks the
amount of parameters isn't that large
because we cannot afford it even though
we have a massive amount of computing
power because the inputs are so large it
would take a lot of time to train a
network of device and so we use a lot
smaller networks instead of techniques
like drop outs we initialize the network
with data flow that we train on which
gives it much better performance because
when we rescale the weights according to
what the what the outputs of each layer
is and we make sure that the output of
each layer is a standard standardized
distribution by scaling the weights
proportionally
okay so now we have this probability map
of the whole volume where the nodules
occur and we take the post-processing
stage is where we threshold these this
probability map and determine for the
connected components that that we have
after the trash operation where the
center is and what the radius is of that
connected components in order to get
some statistics of that nodule and we
call these candidates so the result of
this step is a list of XYZ coordinates
coordinates of all the candidates
service that we find and because we
focused on sensitivity there will be a
lot of false positives at this stage so
the next step we want to reduce these
false positives and this is called
boosting it basically takes the output
of the previous Network and it creates a
patch around each candidate in the
volume in the original volume and we
train another network to determine
whether this is actually a nodule or a
false positive and here you can see some
model and an extra false positive and so
the network is asked to differentiate
between those two categories and
therefore thereby we reduce the error
that the first Network made but we do
not change the center anymore the center
is returned by the first Network so this
step is actually a lot easier and faster
to train these are result that we got
there's a lunar calendar challenge of
determining the long modules in long
scans basically exactly what we do and
we got a top score and at the right you
can see a frog characteristics of our
classifier
and what that means is you on the y-axis
you see the sensitivity and on the
x-axis you can see the average number of
false positives per scan which is the
amount the average amount of false
positives for example at one false
positive per scan we get almost ninety
percent sensitivity and that is already
much better than a radiologist would do
I also want to talk about a little bit
about recent cattle competition that had
that that is held right now it's the
Kegel data Science Bowl and we are also
competing in that type of competition
the cattle competition is to predict
lung cancer on a scan so it's a little
bit different from what we do because we
want to detect lung nodules and this
this competition is to detect whether a
patient gets cancer within a year so
that's a much harder problem actually
because you only have one label per scan
so that is very little label data and
also we only have 1300 scans to train on
and 200 tests 200 scans as a validation
so very little data so what we did is we
use our pipeline to detect lung nodules
on these scans because it's very logical
that lung nodules means that it is an
indication of whether a a patient has
lung cancer or not it is not a guarantee
because of many lung nodules will not
result in cancer but a lung nodule may
have characteristics of lung cancer and
so we train on these candidates that we
get from our pipeline other networks to
determine certain attributes of each
module like speculation and texture
which is basically how the nodule looks
speculate is like
as kind of tentacles in each direction
and also the size of the nodule is very
very important in order to determine
whether it's a cancerous nodule also we
add some extra attributes like XY and Z
location and the distance to the lung
border which are also of great help in
determining whether whether something
else whether a lung nodule is cancerous
and here you couldn't see the model that
we implemented on top of those
attributes that I spoke to you about
earlier and as you can see it's very
easy to implement it's only a few lines
of dense flow code and that that's why
we use sense flow a lot it's a really
good help at what we do and it basically
has everything that we need so we will
fit a linear model but we apply modern
techniques like dropout and noise on top
of it and because we have a lot of
candidates per scan we want to reduce
all the scandals to a certain probe to
one single probability and the way we do
is take by taking the maximum loss loss
over the candidates so with right here
you can see the reduce max function
which is exactly what that does it takes
the maximum over all the linear models
which are defined here so we multiply
the input by weights and Adam bias and
then we take the maximum and then with
built-in function from tens flow we can
calculate the cross entropy and minimize
that and so in only few lines of code
you can create powerful models that you
wouldn't be able to create in order
frameworks
okay finally some comments what deep
learning is awesome for medical imaging
it's it's going to revolutionize the
industry and well we will we are already
seeing great results from it and there's
so much more to do and test out on these
data sets that are huge and that is
that's just discrete these techniques
are are essential to to creating the
performance that we obtain also the size
and quality of our data is very
important as you can see with the cattle
competition we only have 1300 scans if
you would have half a million scans
there's no limits to what we could do
with that so also we you need to think
really carefully about how you design a
model with dense flow because it allows
you to do so much because it's a very
generic framework but you have to watch
out for our fitting and computability in
our case because we have such huge
volumes that we put through the networks
that we quickly have problems that it
will take up a lot of compute power and
finally there's a lot of papers on
archives available including those
techniques like weight enormous Asian
that I talked about and they are a great
resource in the deep learning community
so thank you everybody
you